hello everybody and welcome to part 20
of let's play penumbra overture I have
been in here for about 15 minutes trying
every single permutation everything I
can't figure it out so I'm thinking uh I
miss something either chemical or
instructions I don't know but I miss
something so I'm going back
oh sorry for wasting your time I don't
like to do this ah I don't even have any
jokes prepared oh I'm a terrible let's
player all right oh my gosh give me a
map where the chemical storage up of
course ah big waste of time get away
doggy no one cares about you not even
scary anymore where are the scary
monsters okay okay search in here who's
there huh come on out don't oh come on
ah oh you up come ah
why couldn't I miss like B or something
at least I know I missed it oh that's
the only one that I could have missed
that I wouldn't realize I missed it ah
come on
alright okay I'm cool I'm cool I'm cool
guys and gals ladies I'm cool oh let's
just get this over with
oh now I gotta try them all oh okay but
I'm okay I'm I'm willing and I'm ready
let's do this
okay get ready for some parkour action
it's gonna be intense
shut up
I'm coming I wait and wait oh oh I don't
even have a wrap for you my den of
iniquity I had on the gods of toy
engines me once for sentence meter yet
oh shut up Billy my plight shut up Billy
no maybe my in advice is a dick you have
you rose shut up a little belt please
don't leave poor ray no no it was fall
shucks Holly oh shut up Billy oh oh come
on not only do I miss the only chemical
that I wouldn't notice if I miss it I
miss the only chemical that actually
works oh this is as angering angry you
know what if I wasn't so concise [ __ ]
boom screw that
yeah whatever sorry sorry about that
yeah whatever
ah what the hell what why alright
nevermind okay I guess I have to be
careful oh oh oh I'm so careful Oh
better not do leap parkour oh yeah I'm
so awesome oh yeah oh yeah oh so great
oh I'm careful I'm careful oh look at me
go I'm like a ninja crossed with a cat
oh come on
uh-uh okay alright this is just wasting
time I'm gonna actually be careful oh ah
okay gently ah-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha ah man if
I visit was real life this is where I
die you know besides a warm part and all
that I would blow myself to smithereens
okay just gentle drop yeah all right in
a shop okay we're good we're good
all right and do I chuck it at it uh-huh
okay um oh thank you thank you sir
uh-huh yeah yeah yeah all right oh yeah
boink ah ah run away run away run away
run away uh-huh
boom yeah
I know my fuse links well good thing
these stairs made it what is this oh
it's a ramp okay all right bring it on
who are you oh it's you
Billy Billy Billy I will cut you if you
don't let me in that door oh oh come on
let me in can't get a hold of it with me
with my hands I can get a hold of
anything I got like a 200-pound grip I'm
so off I'll butt up don't be locked up
I will boy uh it's a crowbar it's
perfectly logical John God what's wrong
with you
everything everything's wrong with you
you're dropping your soul in buckets all
over the map God
oh this bread ah I'm not intimidated
chut up
oh he's gonna eat me isn't he oh shut up
handsome I'm handsome
oh shut up I'm not dying like a giant
lizard here I cannot give you the
answers Oh bring it on if you try to
fight me I will destroy you you cannot
know haha so the last megohm doorway or
else you would see anything else in the
world uh-huh no the key stays with me I
want it so the life that is let me
horrible it maybe give it to me that is
still than the light the voice for you
hungry come on let's go you shall be
ever be ignored you're gonna die no
matter what you must wonder why does
mental burning chamber is talking to you
in the voice you Billy Billy
you see I waited Twitter's day so haha
they won't let me die
oh shut up about the mine I love my own
and I could not take my life who did he
go through these Ray's all I was a
friend not your friend
I protected my girl another fire in
India and I hope that soon I so shall my
life yeah by me and I'm gonna answer oh
shut up it's not gonna be tea what's
this uh-huh they are meathook oh yeah
what's under here huh anything value
what's down here oh that looks good I
was at that fan from before probably I
can kill him yeah oh yeah boom oh that's
a bit more vicious than I thought
Oh job's done that's what I intended to
do I suppose why would he be in there I
don't even get it
oh you get this is weird
let's see here all right as soon as you
finish burning which is kind of morbid
but whatever I Billy I'm not sorry
all right I'm little sorry I kind of
that's kind of mean I was just joking
most of the time Billy I mean you were
annoying but she didn't deserve to die
maybe you did
you're trapped there for a long time oh
oh ah really Frankie wasn't my friend
but Phil I guess I'll be respectful
should I do something with his ashes
I'll be respectful I can't do anything
with him okay
they probably originally implemented
that so that you can move his asses
around but then it just got creepy all
right I got a key
I got a key to success bring it on give
me a monster yeah scare me who don't
scare me too bad oh yeah I like that
okay Billy okay
death that's me I'll get out No Billy is
dead yes how'd you know no duh let's see
all right ah yeah oh no aah well it's
just from Billy no I never billions no
Billy well I might be Billy who knows
who knows if Billy actually is it's 1414
old kid down here hope that's not Billy
I hope I didn't kill a kid no he would
be older now but still you know whatever
oh this were a bit listen what where
Billy was oh man oh he put himself oh
that's weird why did he have to die huh
what's in here ah who's there yeah oh I
killed many many dogs so like it's not
even a big deal
oh right here's the bail
yeah ah another one
whisper whisper not Noah's person what
we got here
uh-huh ah Howard in that is internet
John Oh his dad Johnny boy Johnny uh-huh
oh you said the same thing last time
okay anything else anything else all
right
no was he really highlight here I'm not
sure I'm not sure what's going on
symbols fool what's in here who is there
Oh is there oh that's creepy that's
creepy Oh uh-huh
oh and he made me do it ill yeah yeah he
probably did
it's weird oh oh uh uh what why these
but of course why not ah never mind I'm
not even talking about that I'm not in
gracing that with a name get out of
there I know this
boink doodle ooh ah come on
blank doodle doo yep oh yeah I'm great
we got here uh-huh Oh gonna cut them
actually let me pause it here but I'm
not gonna actually stop playing I'm just
gonna keep going I just got to cut the
video so I will see you guys in part 21
bye-bye